- Good morning Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that you have
something special, that
when you unleash it,
it will be able to change the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is
practice public speaking.
Over to you, Warren Buffet.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- One of the things you
would want to be sure to do
is, whether you like it or
not, get very comfortable,
it make take awhile, with
public speaking, for example.
I mean, that's a asset that
will last you 50 or 60 years,
and it's a liability if
you don't like doing it,
or are uncomfortable doing it.
That also will last you 50 or 60 years,
and it's a necessary skill.
- So I'm a big fan of public speaking.
I think if you can learn how to speak,
it can dramatically improve the abilities
to communicate your ideas,
to get your message across,
to grow your business, to build a team.
But I don't know that I would
call it a necessary skill.
I think whatever it is
that you want to do,
you need to be able to bring
people on board to your idea.
Right, as an entrepreneur
it's really really hard
to have success just being a solo person.
So you need to be able
to communicate your idea
to one on one people, to group settings,
and then to large group settings,
and your ability to be
able to do that well
will help you grow a lot faster.
If you can't communicate your
ideas very well to people,
it's going to be a lot
harder to get your project
off the ground.
That being said, and again
this is something that I do
for a living, right, I
massively appreciate the value
of being able to communicate
ideas and be a public speaker.
But that being said, it's
not the only way to win.
I wouldn't call it a necessary skill,
because there's a lot of
other ways that you can stand,
there's a lot of other ways to win.
There's tons of people
who you've never heard of
who are billionaires who
suck at public speaking.
The thing is though, if
that's going to be something
that you ignore, then you
have to really really really
be great at something else.
You have to be off the charts
amazing at something else.
If you are a really poor
public communicator,
then you better be insanely
good at something else.
And so it brings me back
to that teaching a rabbit
how to swim versus how
to hop, you know rabbits
are great at hopping and suck at swimming
and if you try to teach
a rabbit how to swim,
they're going to be average at best.
If you just say, forget about swimming,
focus on hopping, you could
be really really really great.
And so is that equivalent in
your life and your business
for you, your talents, your skillsets.
What's the hopping for you,
and ignoring the swimming part.
I think it's a skill that
everybody should at least try,
you shouldn't just write it
off and say this isn't for me,
this sucks, I'm never going
to be a great speaker.
I think it's a good skillset
if you can develop it
and so it's worth giving a shot.
Just like entrepreneurship,
I think everybody
should at least try to get that idea
that they have in their head out there.
At least try to be an entrepreneur
before writing it off.
Before you write anything off.
Before you say that that food
is not going to be good for you,
or that activity is not
going to be good for you,
at least try it, give it a shot
and see if it feels right, and
see if you want to continue
to push forward and learn more on it.
But the most important thing, I think,
is a self awareness to
figure out who you are,
where you really want to
focus on, what you have
Michael Jordan level talent at,
and the ability to be
among the best in the world
where you're going to apply
yourself, dedicate yourself,
practice hard every single day.
Figure out what it is that you can hop at
and be that bunny for, and
go all in on that skill.
And so the question of the day today is,
I'm curious what are your
thoughts on public speaking?
How good are you at
speaking, is it something
that you want to get better
at, or are you totally
going to disrespect it and
go focus on something else.
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
Please share down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Robb Barco.
Robb, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really
appreciate the support man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- This is going to blow away
people, especially your fan base.
Listening.
You know, I speak a lot,
and I talk over people
and I'm loud and intense
but all of my success
has been predicated on
listening, whether I'm doing it
with my ears, or with my eyes.
- The skill I use is
probably communication.
Which I think is building
on what Gary said.
I think communication is a two way street,
but being able to
articulate and communicate
what it is that I'm trying to communicate,
is something that I find
I focus on all day long,
every time I speak.
- How do you communicate authentically?
How do you figure out what
to say and what not to say
in a way that's authentic.
And what Fred says, and I
really believe this is true,
is it starts from the
fundamental understanding
that there is no truth.
There's my truth, there's your truth,
that everything is subjective.
And so if you always
start from the position of
this is what I believe, I
don't expect you to believe it,
I don't think you have to believe it,
I'm not saying it's true,
you can actually always
communicate authentically.
Because if you walk in the
room, and this gets worse
as you get more senior, here's the answer,
you're not giving anyone else
any room to say anything.
And if you walk into the room and say,
I believe this for this
reason, what do you believe?
If you share your truth in that language,
you give people room to authenticate,
to communicate authentically.
And that is hugely important
to these relationships
at any stage.
- Connecting increases your
influence in every situation.
For the foundation of the teaching today,
I want to make sure that
we really have a grasp
of why connecting with people is so vital.
So if you go to the very
first sentence in your notes,
the number one criteria for
advancement and promotion
for professionals is an ability
to communicate effectively.
That I do believe.
I think the ability to
connect and communicate
is the number one criteria
for success with your family,
with your marriage, with your
children, with your friends,
in the workplace, the
marketplace, in the community.
If you have the ability
to connect with people,
if can communicate and
connect, not just communicate,
it takes you and literally
gives you a decided edge
over others in the advancement
in what we're trying to accomplish.
For example, in your notes
Presidential historian
Robert Alex says that the
successful President's
exhibit five skills and
qualities that enable them
to achieve things that others don't.
So he's talking about
leaders and presidents
and people, what makes some
achieve better than others.
Here's the five things they do well.
Number one is vision,
number two pragmatism,
number three consensus
building; the ability to put
together a team, get consensus.
Number four, charisma, and
number five trustworthiness.
Being a trustworthy kind of a person.
Now, what is interesting about these five,
these five things that
set the better President's
apart from maybe the average ones,
four of the five deal with connecting.
Vision is a definite connecting skill,
the ability to cast a future vision.
Consensus building, getting
people to work together,
you have to be able to connect to do that.
Charisma, of course, that's
why people follow the
quote, the Pied Piper, and trustworthy.
Four of the five of the
skills needed to be successful
as a leader had a lot
to do with connecting.
So let me define connecting,
because that's what this
book is all about.
Connecting is the ability
to identify with people
and relate to them in such
a way that it increases
our influence with them.
In other words, we can identify
with them until they say,
he or she understands exactly what I know
and what I'm going
through, and we can relate
with them until we,
because of that ability,
we begin to increase
our influence with them
and of course what do I teach
about leadership, very simple,
leadership is influence.